brexit was supposed to be done far from
it
trade between great britain and northern
ireland now the center of another brexit
war
the uk government wants to unpick the
very deal
it negotiated and signed the brexit
minister in the lord's demanding a
wholesale
overhaul of trading rules for northern
ireland we've seen difficulties not just
on the famous chilled meats issue but on
medicines
on pets on movements of live animals on
seeds and plants and or many others
put very simply we cannot go on as we
are
the nuclear option of suspending the
current arrangements delayed
for now it is clear that the
circumstances exist
to justify the use of article 16.
nevertheless my lords we have concluded
that it's not the right moment
to do so instead we see an opportunity
to
proceed differently to find a new path
to seek to agree with the eu
through negotiations a new balance in
our arrangements covering northern
ireland
to the benefit of all a brexit
arrangement
hailed by the prime minister as oven
ready a great deal for the people of
northern ireland
18 months later it turns out it was
anything but
the pm now wants to deal again asking
the eu for a near elimination
of checks they know in there it will go
down badly in brussels and that's not
just because of the substance
of the demands but also because of the
lack of trust now
in the johnson government the eu says it
will not renegotiate
but it has hinted it will at least play
ball and perhaps avert
a trade war island's europe minister
clear where his continental colleagues
are coming from
our position and i think the position of
all our colleague member states is that
there's enough
leeway within the treaties and protocol
that we've agreed
uh to make this thing uh move forward
and to give finality and certainty to
the situation without
without the fall our position is that we
don't want to renegotiate the protocol
position set little hope of a
breakthrough anytime soon
the uk has asked the eu to at least
agree a standstill period
to give negotiations more time i don't
think either side particularly northern
ireland wants to see a significant
escalation of tension
so um you can see the attractiveness of
at least
um you know having that standstill
kicking the cannabis and trying to find
more time for negotiation and that
that's my instinct at the moment because
on the substance i think the two sides
are still just very far apart
the summer break in westminster and
brussels will take the heat out of this
row
for a few weeks at least but cool heads
will be required in the autumn
to resolve the standoff beth rigby sky
news westminster